[Music]
rivian lucid lordstown canoe and fiskar
five ev startups i profiled a year ago
that all elicited high valuations under
the promise of creating electric
vehicles that could take on tesla's
dominance but fast forward to today and
the share price of those companies has
plummeted part of the reason well some
of these newcomers simply haven't made
as many cars as they'd hoped and all of
them are yet to turn a profit operating
a plant that's not producing a lot of
cars i mean there's no better way to run
through cash and now some are hitting a
make or break moment so where do these
companies stand and what are they doing
to survive let's find out
firstly if you want a snapshot of where
these companies were a year ago then go
check out the profile i made on them
back in 2021. back then none of these
companies had actually produced a
commercial vehicle in the auto industry
nothing is harder than like trying to
move from a prototype to mass production
that's wsj's detroit bureau chief
christina rogers who told me that while
trying to make a new car can be
challenging for any automaker trying to
do so at a time of supply chain woes
covered outbreaks chip shortages
geopolitical unrest the tech sell-off
and inflation can make it even harder
it's hard for even the traditional
automakers for smaller companies with
unproven track records it's even harder
for them to get suppliers to trust them
or to put them at the top of the list in
a recent letter to investors rivian said
that its card launchers have been
executed during one of the most complex
operating environments in decades
lordstown says like many others in the
industry it has suffered from part
shortages and raw material availability
canoe ceo told me that on any given day
the company is wrestling with supply for
around 60 parts though it's a fraction
of the 1800 that go into making the
vehicle rivien said semiconductor
shortages had led to delays and lucid
has said that difficulty getting hold of
carpet and glass had hampered its
production efforts visco meanwhile said
it was working with manufacturers magnet
and foxconn to proactively address any
supply chain challenges
so how many cars have these companies
actually made or delivered because there
is a difference and what do delays mean
for them well rivien slashed its 2022
production forecast from 50 000 to 25
000 vehicles so far the company says
it's manufactured around 5000 units
since it started production in 2021.
luxury sedan maker lucid also cut its
forecast from 20 000 to between 12 and
14 000 vehicles
so far it says it's delivered 360. and
while canoe said it hopes to produce
between 3 000 to 6 000 vehicles in 2022
so far it's only made 39 of its gamma
testing models and is currently
producing around eight vehicles a week
lordstown which had hoped to be
producing vehicles in september 2021
pushed back production to the third
quarter of 2022 and has said it needs to
raise an additional 150 million dollars
in capital before the end of the year
fiska however says it remains on track
to produce its first vehicles this year
not producing many or any vehicles means
one thing none of these companies is
turning a profit they're carrying heavy
losses in the first quarter of 2022
these companies posted millions of
dollars in losses and while rivien and
lucid are both sat on sizable
investments both canoe and lordstown
have at separate times said there is a
substantial doubt about the company's
ability to continue when i asked about
their losses lucid and fiskar declined
to comment lordstown referred me to
their earnings and rivien referred me to
a previous wsj interview canoe however
told me their strategy was to raise
capital whenever they hit major
milestones so what can these companies
do to try and survive well one method is
to simplify configuration options to get
more vehicles off the production line in
an investor call rivian said it was
doing just that prioritizing certain
trim options to maximize the number of
vehicles it can produce another method
is to simply raise the price of your
vehicle both rivian and lucid have done
just that raising the price for
customers who haven't pre-ordered before
a certain date and fiska 2 has said it
can't commit to pricing after the first
40 000 units all vehicles produced from
2024 onwards others have sold off assets
to generate more cash lordstown recently
sold off its ohio factory to foxconn you
will manufacture lordstown's vehicle for
a purchase price of 230 million dollars
and where you make your vehicle can make
a difference canoe told me they'd move
manufacturing from europe to the us to
be less exposed to currency swings and
supply chain snarls
so will these companies make it well
christina said that changes in
production or delivery rates was the
simplest way to tell whether these
companies were overcoming their
production was but if 2022 has taught us
one thing it's that supply chains are
fragile so even if production rates
increase it might be worth keeping an
eye on how much cash these companies
have left honestly the evs that have the
most cash or have easy access to cash
are probably the ones that are going to
prevail this business is very simple
cost a lot of money to build a car and
get a car off the ground
and if you don't have it that's it
game over
[Music]